♪♪♪
♪ IN WEST PHILADELPHIA
BORN AND RAISED
ON THE PLAYGROUND IS WHERE
I SPENT MOST OF MY DAYS ♪
♪ WITH A COUPLE GUYS THAT
WERE UP TO NO GOOD
STARTING MAKING TROUBLE
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD ♪
♪ I GOT IN ON LITTLE FIGHT
AND MY MOM GOT SCARED
SHE SAID ♪
♪ YOU'RE MOVING IN WITH YOUR
AUNTIE AND UNCLE
IN BEL AIR ♪
♪ I LOOKED AT MY KINGDOM
I WAS FINALLY THERE
TO SIT ON MY ♪
♪ THRONE AS THE
PRINCE OF BEL AIR ♪
♪ THE GUYS I FOUGHT WEREN'T
REGULAR THUGS
THEY WERE A POWERFUL GANG
RUNNING GUNS AND DRUGS ♪
♪ AND BECAUSE OF OUR FIGHT
ONE WENT TO JAIL SO THEY
FOLLOWED ME ALL OF THE WAY
OUT TO BEL AIR ♪
>> LET'S GO TO BEL AIR AND KILL
THAT NERD!
♪ THEY BARGED RIGHT THROUGH
THE DOOR AND STARTED
TRASHING THE PLACE
MY UNCLE PHIL GOT UP ♪
♪ IN THE LEADER'S FACE
HE SAID, SON I'M A JUDGE
YOU BETTER THINK TWICE ♪
♪ THEN THEY BEAT MY UNCLE
PHIL WITHIN AN INCH OF
LIFE ♪
>> CALL SOMEBODY, CALL THE COPS!
♪ CARLTON THEN PISSED HIS
KHAKIS AND SNITCHED ME OUT
HE'S HIDING OUTSIDE
IN THE POOL HOUSE ♪
♪ AND SO I GOT OUT OF
THERE AS QUICK AS
I CAME ♪
♪ LAY LOW AT A MOTEL
HIDING FROM THAT GANG ♪
♪ THIS IS --
[ KNOCKING ]
>> WHO IS THERE?
♪ THEN THIS LADY SHOWS
UP AND HERE IS
WHAT SHE SAID ♪
♪ I'M FBI YOU STAY HERE
YOU'RE DEAD
AT THAT VERY MOMENT I WAS
FROZEN BY WITH FEAR ♪
♪ SHE SAID IF YOU WANT
TO STAY ALIVE YOU GOT
TO DISAPPEAR ♪
♪ CUT TO THE CITY MORGUE
WHERE I'M SCARED AND
CONFUSED ♪
♪ SHE'S DRESSING A
DEAD BODY IN MY CLOTHES
AND MY SHOES ♪
♪ SAYS SHE NEEDS MY TEETH
AND A COUPLE OF HAIRS
TO MAKE THE THUGS ♪
♪ THINK THE BODY'S
THE FRESH PRINCE OF
BEL AIR ♪
>> THE BODY IN THE CAR HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A PHILADELPHIA MAN
WHO ACCORDING TO FRIENDS ENJOYED
CHILLING OUT MAX AND RELAXING
ALL COOL AND --
♪ I WATCHED MY FUNERAL FROM
BEHIND A TREE
I SAW MY MOMMA CRY
AS THEY BURIED ME ♪
♪ I SAID CAN'T I JUST LET
HER KNOW THAT
I'M ALRIGHT SHE SAID ♪
♪ NOW YOU'RE A GHOST, SAY GOOD
NIGHT.
♪ I WOKE UP IN A WAREHOUSE
ON A METAL SEAT WITH A
SCARY JAPANESE MAN LOOKING AT
ME ♪
>> THE DEBT IS REPAID.
♪ THE FED SAID TO THE MAN
I ASKED WHAT THE [ BLEEP ] IS
HAPPENING ♪
♪ SHE SAID I'M NOT FBI
BUT I'M SORRY I USED YOU
BUT MY FATHER OWES A LOT
OF MONEY TO THE YAKUZA ♪
♪ SO ALL OF THIS WAS JUST
A CRAZY PLOY ♪
>> SILENCE WORM, NOW YOU'RE A
NOBODY BOY.
♪ DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS
DIDN'T WANT TO FIND OUT
BUT THEY BURNED OFF MY ♪
♪ FINGERPRINTS AND THEY DUCT
TAPED MY MOUTH ♪
♪ THEN GUNSHOT AND THE
HENCHMAN DROPPED
THE PHILLY THUGS ENTERED
HOLDING 9'S AND GLOCKS ♪
>> HEY YO, PHILLY'S MY TOWN
AKIRA!
♪ SAID THE THUG TO THE MAN
SO GATHER UP YOUR
CREW AND GO BACK TO JAPAN ♪
♪ THE MAN JUST SMILED THEN
QUIETLY ANSWERED
GENTLEMEN PLEASE TEACH OUR
GUESTS SOME MANNERS ♪
♪ BOTH CREWS OPENED UP
BULLETS WERE FLYING PAST
THE RED HEAD GOT HIT
WITH A SHOTGUN BLAST ♪
♪ IN THE SHADOWS STOOD
A MAN NOBODY KNEW WHO
HE WAS ♪
>> WHO THE HELL ARE YOU?
>> YOU CAN CALL ME THE JUDGE.
♪ UNCLE PHIL SAID YOU NEED
TO GET OFF THE GRID YOU CAN
NEVER GO BACK TO THE LIFE
THAT YOU LIVED ♪
♪ SO I CRAWLED ON THE FLOOR
PAST THE RED HEADED TRAITOR
AND HER LAST WORDS WERE ♪
♪ YO HOMES SMELL
YA LATER ♪
[ GUNSHOTS ]
♪ AND THAT'S MY STORY
ALL ABOUT HOW
MY LIFE GOT FLIPPED
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN ♪
♪ AND IF ANYBODY ASKS
JUST SIT RIGHT THERE
AND TELL THEM HOW I
BECAME -- ♪
>> JASPER MITCHELL OF
WHITERIDGE, NEW HAMPSHIRE.
♪♪♪